لم يكن السودان استثناء من تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا فالبلاد تعتمد على
الاستيراد لتلبيه 65% من حاجتها من القمح
وياتي نحو 95% من تلك النسبه من روسيا
واوكرانيا وفي ظل المخاوف من استمرار
تداعيات الحرب فان التحديات تتضاعف على
عاتق المسؤولين لتامين غذاء ملايين
السودانيين الذين يعتمدون على رغيف الخبز
في معاشيهم اليومي الدوله كانت تنتج حوالي
700 الف طن في العام واستهلاك الدوله
حوالي 2.5 مليون طن بالتالي كانت تشكل او
توفر حوالي 30% من استهلاك البلاد ولكن
متوقع ان هذه نسبه تتراجع واذا استمر امد
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لفتره طويله
سيتاثر امداد الحبوب بالنسبه للسودان
بصوره كبيره باعتبار السودان يعتمد على
الامداد من روسيا واوكرانيا بنسبه مقدره
وفي حين تقلل وزاره الماليه السودانيه من
تاثيرات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا على
قطاع القمح تؤكد ان سلاسل الامداد تعتمد
الى جانب روسيا واوكرانيا على دول اخرى
بالتنسيق مع القطاع الخاص توفر هذه السلعه
مرده ان القطاع الخاص اصبح يعني يعمل
تجاريا ويستورد هذه السلعه من دول مختلفه
او المصادر المختلفه من استراليا وغيرها
وغيرها
اما هنا في المخابز وبرغم شكاوي اصحابها
من ارتفاع تكاليف مدخلات الانتاج بين انهم
يؤكدون ان امدادات دقيق القمح تشهد
استقرارا جيدا مقارنه بالفترات الماضيه
الدقيقه مستغر في الفتره دي اي نعم هو
ماذا اول لكن برضو ما يتقطع مننا بيجينا
بالصوره متواصله بقينا بصوره لو مايو ميا
يوم بعد يوم رغم استقرار الخبز واسعاره
حاليا في السودان لان المواطن البسيط ظل
رهينا لاضطرابات خارجيه تؤثر على معاشه
مثل الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتي تبدو
انها طويله المدى سالم الهاشمي العربي
الخرطوم